should you upgrade from the iphone 13
pro to the iphone 14 pro well today i'm
gonna make it easy by giving you guys
both the good and the bad what has
changed and what hasn't and what is
disappointing now apple focused on power
efficiency the displays and the cameras
for the iphone 14 pro models now the
first thing that stands out are the new
colors we have this deep purple instead
of the sierra blue and space black
instead of graphite which looks a little
bit darker in some lighting and much
darker in others gold and silver still
remain but one interesting thing is that
the white back on the silver is now an
actual white instead of being a warmer
tone if you care about battery life it
has improved by one hour and that is
only for video playback and streaming
has stayed the same meaning that we do
not have a more efficient cellular modem
and max safe charging still isn't any
faster now one thing to keep in mind is
the apple is still not giving you a
charger but these phones actually accept
more than the 20 watt that they want to
sell you 23 watts on one and up to 27 on
the 14 pro max so if you're gonna buy a
charger buy a 30 watt model to get the
fastest charging we will link our
recommended one down below some more
things that have not changed is the
ceramic shield glass so it is not any
stronger and with that the waterproofing
isn't any better now thankfully another
thing that didn't change are the prices
they are still exactly the same with the
same 128 gigabyte storage going up to
one terabyte but there are some killer
trade-in offers we are getting all four
models for comparison and testing so if
you want to see that along with our
iphone 14 buyers guide that's coming out
tomorrow make sure to click that
subscribe button below unfortunately we
still don't have wi-fi 6e but we do have
new bluetooth 5.3 which will be used for
the new airpods pro and with that apple
did not mention any better cooling on
the 14 pro and pro max models and we had
the issue of screen dimming under load
so hopefully that gets better and we'll
talk about the chip performance in a bit
now a lot of people also wanted stronger
mac safe magnets but nope they are the
same so if you're using one of apple's
wallets you will not get any stronger of
a connection now personally i ditched my
apple wallet after i bought this moth
one a year and a half ago and it not
only has stronger magnets it holds more
cards it has a stand and a grip it is
half the price and it is just amazing i
recommend it to everybody and our
partners at moff have launched some new
colors for these new iphones and not
only is it stronger by itself but when
you pair it with their case it is two
times stronger so the max safe magnets
not improving isn't really an issue if
you guys want to check these out highly
recommend them check them out down below
now a big downside for me is that there
is no more sim slot in the iphone 14s so
it is all esim now that is more secure
but that means you just can't pop out a
sim and put another one in so i don't
like that and of course we still don't
have usb type-c it's just lighting onto
the displays this is where we have
massive differences and it's going to
make a lot of people want to upgrade now
sizes are the same but the bezels are
thinner resulting in the phones being
slightly narrower and there's a little
bit thicker just because of the cameras
overall not a huge difference but the
screen is slightly sharper because of
more pixels what really matters to me is
the brightness not only are we at 1600
nits peaks or hdr is better when you are
outdoors it will hit 2 000 nits peak
which is insane previously it was a
thousand if you're not doing hdr so if
you're somebody that struggles outside
with brightness this is going to be
incredible now not only that something
i've been asking since the iphone 10
came out was for an always on display
now apple finally gave it to us and they
did it right the whole screen dims all
your content is still there and looks
fantastic it's upgrading in the
background so i cannot wait for that i
often have my phone sitting next to me
and i want to see what's going on in
updates without having to tap it to turn
it on now they're able to do that
because the screen goes down to one
hertz refresh rate which saves power i
can't wait you guys let me know if you
guys care about this but of course the
biggest thing that stands out is the
pale cutout that apple is calling the
dynamic island now we saw leaks we saw
rumors some people loved it some people
didn't it uses 30 percent less space
because it's not attached in the
proximity sensors behind the screen but
what we did not expect is the way the
apple's gonna use it as part of the ui
that will bubble up and show you alerts
tons of apps can use it it is fully
interactive and it can even stay on
active while you're using things like
navigation recording and a bunch of
different stuff and if you have two apps
that can use it it'll show up both you
can like open it up and have access to
controls now i'm personally so excited
about this everybody hated the notch we
wanted it gone and not only did they
change it to make it look different but
they took a negative from a cutout or
something taking you know room on your
screen and made it into a positive that
is actually used for so i am just super
excited because uh it looks better and
then with that if you're worried about
it cutting into video when you're
watching the bottom of that pill or the
island it actually lines up where the
notch used to be so if you don't stretch
out video on your screen you're not
gonna have that in your shot and now for
some bad news with the a16 bionic chip
if you wanted more performance and if
you wanted more graphics performance
well you're gonna be disappointed
because
there is very little differences now it
is a four nanometer process not five
nanometers so that was shocking and
apple really focused on how much better
it is in the competition it is 40 faster
we still have a 5 core gpu with 50 more
memory bandwidth the cpu is still 6 core
but they just talked about the lower
power usage 20 lower for the high
performance scores and overall it uses a
third of the power of the best
efficiency cores from the competition so
very impressive there now of course you
would think you'd get better battery
life but you don't and that is just
because of all the extra brightness and
the always-on mode with that display now
i mentioned earlier that they didn't
talk about any dimming issues or any uh
better cooling system
since this chip uses a lot less power
even though the performance is going to
be the same as the a15 which let's face
it the performance is great
because of less heat that is where we
can see less dimming issues when you're
doing things like gaming so we're very
excited to test that out head to head
with the iphone 13 pro now before i
cover the major differences in cameras i
have to talk about safety because this
is major and a lot of people are going
to want to upgrade the first one is
crash detection which is fantastic but
the biggest one is the satellite
connectivity even without cellular or
wi-fi service you can still reach out
for emergency services you can send text
messages they made this whole ui and it
took them years to design it that allows
you to choose messages quickly and be
able to send them out while following a
satellite since the iphones don't have
these large external antennas because of
that it takes about 15 seconds to send a
text or up to two minutes if there's
some foliage and apples create this
whole setup to relay messages into calls
with call centers to be able to figure
out how to come and help you out so for
emergency uses if you're somebody that
hikes or you just go out somewhere it is
so nice to have this feature and if it's
not an emergency you can still use the
find my app to send your location to
other people so that is just absolutely
game changing and groundbreaking to have
that now one thing apple didn't mention
is that this will be a paid for service
but they said you will get two years for
free if you buy one of these phones now
i think it's gonna be another way to get
people to upgrade every two years
instead of every three or four which is
now becoming the trend but that just
might make it worth it for you and now
let's talk about the cameras for most
people their phone is their main device
to take cameras with i shoot most of my
stuff with it because it's convenient
i'm saving memories for my kids and i
want to see some nice updates now
thankfully the 14 pro and 14 pro max
have the same cameras because there were
rumors that the max one would have
better ones now they both have 48
megapixel sensors that have 65 larger
sensors and a fast lens and they're
slightly wider as well now this will
typically combine four pixels into one
so you'll still have a small 12
megapixel image but that effectively
gives you four times more light and
overall two times better than the iphone
13 pro now if you want to save all of
that 48 megapixel detail you can do so
but you're gonna have to use the pro raw
option which uses a lot more space and
that's just a way to get people that
don't need it to not use it now one
really cool thing is a new 2x crop mode
from that main sensor that gives you
more control if you're coming from the
iphone 11 where you had 2x lens or maybe
the 2.5 from the 12 or even the 3x one
here sometimes i just am way too close
for a 3x but too far from a 2x so for
porsche shots i would just take one
wider image and then have to crop in
later this gives you a lot more
flexibility now with that it can have
worse low light performance so at times
the 3x lens will still give you better
photos now unfortunately the 3x lens has
not changed at all and this was the lens
that had the most issues focusing
overall they're just using software to
give you better low light performance
but it hasn't changed so if you're
somebody like me that wanted a better
zoom lens something closer what samsung
offers while the quality will not get
any better as far as the ultrawide it is
new with a darker f 2.2 aperture
compared to f 1.7 in order to improve
sharpness which is great because this
was the least sharp lens and because of
that software their photonic they have
three times better low light performance
so that is huge so the worst lens is now
maybe even the most improved now the
front camera has also gotten better and
now has autofocus for the first time
which means for those wider shots
they're going to look a lot sharper and
it is also two times better in low light
because of software and lastly if you
like to use flash that is all new as
well it is twice as bright and more
uniform now for those of you guys who
shoot a lot of video like i do a huge
disappointment is that we are not
getting 8k like we had rumored now it is
possible with this sensor and with the
a16 bionic processor so that's a huge
bummer for me i want to save my videos
for my kids for my grandkids
and we're not going to get that detail
maybe is it because apple wants all the
cameras to shoot ak when they finally
offer it or maybe this want you to
upgrade next year who knows but that is
a downside now on the positive we have
the new action mode that will record the
full sensor and then crop in to give you
super smooth footage which is awesome
but they did not mention that it's not
4k it actually lowers the quality but as
far as the cinematic mode with that blur
if you're somebody to love to use it
like my wife does
that is now 4k when also hdr so overall
quality is much improved so with all of
that said should you upgrade from your
iphone 13 pro to the iphone 14 pro
well every year we think the apple can't
make the phone that much better and most
years they really surprise us you know
we had promotion last year well now we
have the always on display personally i
think the most game-changing features
are the screen that can get way brighter
in daylight it's a real world usability
feature the safety features with the
satellite connectivity and getting rid
of that notch that is just a nicety it
is a luxury it is not as is not a
necessity basically and as far as the
cameras yes the quality is going to get
better but most people are happy with
their iphone 13 photos or even the 12.
now personally we are going to be doing
a comparison not only a blind one but
we're going to compare the 12 the 13 and
the 14 to show you guys their real world
differences just like we have in
previous years to show you isn't really
that much better for what you do so you
guys can you know subscribe to check
that out uh but overall i think that for
a lot of people if you don't care about
the safety features with the satellite
and if you don't care about the screen
getting brighter some of the camera
improvements you don't really need to
upgrade the phone looks the same your
iphone 13 works well so in that case
it's not huge for me i care about
cameras and i care about display so of
course i'm going to upgrade now if
you're somebody that's coming from an
iphone 12 or even an iphone 11 this is
where you're gonna have a big big
difference
overall and cameras is going to be huge
and screen's going to get huge you're
going to get the pro motion uh the
battery life is a lot better compared to
the iphone 12 in that case i would say
yeah it is a good time to upgrade so you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below click above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]